Географія!
Де б не був би я,
Допоможе мені зорієнтуватися
Яка країна і де вона,
В яке море впадає ця ріка,
Блискучий Колумб та Марко Поло
Географія навколо планети Земля!
Шановні дев'ятикласники,
вітаю вас на уроці географії!
З вами учитель Галина Іванівна Карпюк.
Тема уроку: "Виробництво
харчових продуктів".
Перший урок цієї теми: "Виробництво
харчових продуктів в Україні".
На наступному уроці ми розглянемо
харчову промисловість світу.
Це остання тема з розділу
"Вторинний сектор економіки"
і з цим також варто
привітати дев`ятикласників.
Що виробляє харчова промисловість?
Уявіть собі, що ви у великому
продуктовому магазині.
Перед вами полиці з хлібом і булочками,
потім молочні продукти, м`ясні,
кондитерські вироби, консервовані
овочі і фрукти,
напої, солодкі, слабоалкогольні,
алкогольні - це все харчова промисловість.
І ось таке розмаїття продуктів виробляє
дуже багато підприємств в Україні
і тому не так просто розібратися
зі всіма особливостями
сучасної просторової
організації цього виробництва.
Якщо ми відкриємо карту
харчової промисловості,
то помітим одну закономірність:
багато кольорів
і, майже рівномірно розміщені по території
центри або осередки
промислового виробництва.
Отже, харчова промисловість
поділяється на багато окремих виробництв,
перелік яких ви зустрінете
в КВЕДі а також,
майже рівномірно розташовані
виробництва по території України.
Це істотно відрізняє
харчову промисловість, наприклад,
від, чорної або кольорової металургії,
паливної промисловості, електроенергетики,
окремих виробництв машинобудування
чи хімічної промисловості.
Разом з тим - це та галузь, яка
працює безпосередньо на споживача.
Вироблені продукти харчування
купляють всі люди,
які живуть в нашій країні.
Вироблені продукти харчування
можуть стати необхідними
витратами для підприємств,
які надають послуги,
наприклад, кафе і ресторани.
Це можуть бути навіть
шкільні їдальні і кафетерії.
Це можуть бути підприємства,
які фасують ці продукти,
постачають для продажу в
магазини, тобто є посередниками.
Харчова промисловість - це одна
з провідних галузей в Україні,
яка крім того, що виробляє
необхідні нам товари,
забезпечує значний обсяг
валютної виручки в нашій країні,
адже це експортна галузь.
Або, як ми ще кажемо,
це виробництво, що є складником
міжнародної спеціалізації України.
Як побудована карта
харчової промисловості?
Передусім, ми бачимо,
що в основі лежить картограма.
Є області що виділені темним
фоном, світлішим і ще світлішим.
В легенді карти ви побачите,
що це обсяг продовольчих товарів,
який вироблений в розрахунку
на одного мешканця цієї області.
Та, якщо глянути в цілому на карту,
то галузь "харчова промисловість"
має істотні відмінності по рівню
концентрації щодо кількості населення.
Тобто, дивіться:
Київська область - темний фон,
тому що тут Київ і область працює на
забезпечення великого міста-мільйонника.
Темним фоном позначений, наприклад,
Харківська область, Дніпропетровська -
це області з великою кількістю населення,
і разом з тим це області які
передусім обслуговують великі міста.
Якщо ми глянемо на Волинську область -
кількість міського населення
там значно менша,
але при цьому область має
прикордонне положення.
Так само, як наприклад Миколаївська.
Це означає, що підприємства цих областей
працюють як на внутрішній ринок України,
так і на зовнішній.
Отже,
картограма показує
порівняння - обсяг виробництва
з кількістю населення.
А кружечки з кольорами в них -
це осередки промислового виробництва.
Це можуть бути в харчовій промисловості
великі міста, середні, малі,
селища міського типу і навіть села.
Щоб зрозуміти як
розташовується це виробництво,
познайомимося з такою табличкою,
яка умовно поділяє всі ці
виробництва на дві підгрупи:
ті, які орієнтуються на сировину, і
ті, які орієнтуються на споживача.
Споживчі сировинні чинники
вам уже відомі з попередніх уроків.
А от є виробництва, які в
однаковій мірі орієнтуються
як на джерела сировини,
так і на споживачів.
До орієнтованих на сировину належать:
цукрове, олійне,
крохмальне, круп`яне, консервне,
маслоробне, рибне та інші виробництва.
Це означає, що в основному
вони розташовуються там,
де є джерела сировини, тобто
продовольство, яке виробляється
в сільському господарстві,
в рибному господарстві.
На споживача орієнтуються
дещо інші виробництва.
Ті, які передусім виробляють продукцію
с коротким терміном зберігання,
або ту продукцію,
яку складно транспортувати
щоб вона зберігала свою якість.
Наприклад, щоб до столу
завжди був свіжий хліб,
свіже тістечко, чи інші
кондитерські вироби.
Не зіпсовані, не поламані під час
транспортування макаронні вироби,
безалкогольні напої з
коротким терміном зберігання.
А от такі, як борошномельне виробництво,
м’ясне, молочне,
виноробне, лікеро-горілчане -
вони можуть орієнтуватися і
на сировину, і на споживача.
Почнемо з групи виробництв,
які орієнтуються на сировину.
Перед вами карта
сільського господарства.
Зональна спеціалізація відображає
майже природні зони України.
Ось так розташовані, в
основному, виробництва,
які мають оптимальні умови для
розвитку в зоні Українського Полісся.
Ось ми маємо зону Лісостепу.
Високу концентрацію виробництв,
які орієнтуються на агрокліматичні
ґрунтові ресурси Лісостепової зони.
А ось зона степу,
Північного та Південного.
І тут ми бачимо дещо інші кольори і
інший рівень концентрації виробництва.
Окремо виділяється
Карпатський регіон і Кримські гори.
Якщо поглянути на цю карту, то в кожній
зоні ми помічаємо такі рожеві плямки.
Це виробництва, які орієнтуються на
постачання свіжих продовольчих продуктів
у великі міста і ми називаєм це
приміськими
сільськогосподарськими районами.
Які ж виробництва і як
розташовані в Україні?
Передусім,
почнемо з тих, які
визначають міжнародну
спеціалізацію України.
Це олійножирова промисловість і цукрова.
Виробництво рослинних олій в Україні
сконцентроване, в основному,
в лісостеповій і степовій зоні.
Але сьогодні картина дещо змінюється.
Пов’язано це з тим, що змінюється зональна
спеціалізація сільського господарства.
Виробництво олії
ми маємо тут у вигляді ось
таких пунсонів рожевого кольору.
Якщо я вам зараз їх просто покажу
так, щоб ви могли їх побачити,
не читаючи назви міст.
Якщо ви дивитися в атлас, то також
намагайтесь покласти його подалі від себе,
щоб ви не зосереджувались
на назвах міст і містечок.
Щоб ви бачили просто
розташування цих пунсонів.
Тоді ви краще зможете зрозуміти
просторову закономірність.
Подивіться, як розташовані ці виробництва.
Одне біля одного досить густо.
А ось на цій території рожевих
пунсонів практично немає.
На цій території ми їх бачимо дуже мало.
Ось лише один.
Давайте візьмем оранжеві пунсони.
Ось їх багато отут,
в цьому районі.
Дещо менше стає
в зоні лісостепу.
І майже не зустрічається,
поки що, на Поліссі.
Ця карта ще не містить тих
підприємств, які тільки будуються.
Що ми маємо?
Олійножирова промисловість -
це оранжеві пунсони.
Виробляють олію в Україні із соняшника,
із сої, із рапсу
або ріпаку.
Якщо ми подивимося на
структуру виробництва олії в Україні,
то передусім це традиційне наше
виробництво - соняшникова олія.
Якщо подивитись на цю
діаграму, вчимося працювати із
статистичними матеріалами,
наведеними у вигляді діаграми.
Ми бачимо, що є
підприємства, які забезпечують більше
1О відсотків виробництва олії в Україні.
Це не означає, що це
підприємство - це єдиний завод.
Це підприємство може мати
кілька заводів, розташованих
в одній області чи навіть
в кількох сусідніх областях.
Але вони об`єднані спільним
керівництвом, спільною формою власності.
Основні підприємства-лідери розташовані:
місто Дніпро, Одеська область,
Полтавська, Львівська, Харківська,
Кропивницький і Кіровоградська область.
Знову Полтавська, знову ми бачимо
Дніпропетровська, Запорізька область.
Це ті області, які зосереджені
в лісостеповій і степовій зоні.
Там знаходяться великі підприємства.
Чому там?
Тому що саме в степовій і лісостеповій
зоні зосереджені основні посіви соняшника.
Якщо ми подивимося зону Полісся,
то ми не бачимо тут
великих оранжевих пунсонів,
начебто і немає того виробництва,
але нові підприємства - великі, сучасні
починають поступово
рухатися на північ України.
Чому?
Тому що
за соняшником, за сировинною зоною,
переміщується виробництво.
А виробництво соняшника, як ви вивчали,
воно зміщується у північні
області, північно-західні,
тому що вони краще забезпечені вологою.
І вирішити проблему невисокої
родючості ґрунтів значно простіше,
ніж забезпечити вологою
тривалий засушливий період
господарства, розташовані
в південних областях України.
Таким чином,
олійножирова промисловість
розташована як у великих містах,
навіть мільйонниках, або
як Дніпро, або, наприклад,
великі міста, таки як
Запоріжжя чи Вінниця,
так і в маленьких містах України.
А невеликі приватні виробництва,
які можуть виробляти
рафіновану чи нерафіновану олію,
розташовані навіть у
селищах міського типу і селах.
Спробуємо подивитися
як змінювалось виробництво олії
і що ми маємо на сьогодні.
1999 рік - стартовий.
Менше трьох мільйонів гектарів
площа соняшників.
Виробництво олії - 570 тисяч тон.
Експорт насіння соняшника -
500 тисяч тон,
а експорт олії - 174.
Тобто,
експорт насіння втричі
перевищує експорт олії.
В 1999 році Верховна Рада України
вводить експортне мито
на насіння соняшника.
Стрімко змінюється картина.
Площа посівів ще незначно зросла,
але виробництво олії
зростає майже вдвічі.
Таким чином,
уряд України змінює ситуацію в країні.
Україна з експортера
соняшникового насіння
перетворюється в експортера олії,
адже експорт олії також зростає втричі.
Якщо ми візьмемо період 1О років потім,
ми маємо вже в півтора
рази збільшені площі посівів.
Суттєво збільшене виробництво олії.
І подивіться на скільки зросло
виробництво і експорт олії.
І, нарешті, 2019 рік.
6 мільйонів гектарів
посівів соняшника в Україні.
Я не можу сказати - добре це чи погано.
З однієї сторони - добре,
тому що поле не "гуляє".
З другої сторони -
соняшник, це та культура,
яка виснажує ґрунти
і в умовах сталого розвитку ми
мали б дотримуватися сівозміни,
і на кожному полі не частіше аніж
раз у 7 років висівати соняшник.
Але сьогодні експорт олії
перевищує 5 мільйонів 700 тисяч тон,
а експорт насіння усього 73.
На чому ми зупинитись маємо?
Це дуже позитивне зрушення,
як один із прикладів позитивних змін у
виробництві харчових продуктів в Україні.
З виробництва і експорту
соняшникового насіння,
яке коштує майже вдвічі дешевше
на світовому ринку ніж олія,
ми переходимо до
виробництво і експорт олії.
Тобто ми виробляєм з тієї
ж сировини другий продукт,
який має вищу додану вартість,
він приносить значно
більшу експортну виручку,
і при цьому це створені
додатково робочі місця,
це додатково заробітна
плата наших працівників.
Це зростання валового
внутрішнього продукту,
зростання добробуту населення.
Тобто, такі зміни варто тільки вітати
і олійна промисловість - один
із прикладів таких змін.
Експорт олії приносить сьогодні
Україні понад 4 мільярда доларів.
Це перше місце в світі.
Більше половини світового експорту
соняшникової олії забезпечує Україна.
А сьогодні ми стаємо ще й експортерами
олії, виробленої з інших культур:
соєвої олії, ріпакової олії.
Крім олії
Україна експортує
побічні продукти олійного
виробництва, або, як ми
можемо сказати, "відходи".
Називаємо ми їх макухою.
Ось цей шрот, або
макуха - це той продукт,
який міг би використовуватися
в тваринництві,
якби ми успішно розвивали
тваринництво в Україні.
А поки що ми цей цінний продукт,
який ми відносим до кормових,
експортуємо більше як
на мільярд доларів на рік.
Таким чином,
олійна промисловість України -
це не тільки робочі
місця і заробітні плати,
не тільки валовий
продукт і сплачені податки,
олійна промисловість -
це велика валютна виручка,
яка стримує курс гривні
на гарних позиціях в Україні
і забезпечує позитивніший
торгівельний баланс України.
Виробництво цукру також експортне
і належить до галузей
міжнародної спеціалізації.
Оскільки цукрова промисловість
позначена рожевими пунсонами, які
погано видно на карті,
я пропоную вам
розглянути таку картосхему.
На ній вже чітко позначені
розміщені цукрові заводи в Україні.
На 2019 рік їх уже 46 у
12-ти областях України.
Якщо ви
отак віддалено розглянете карту атласу,
або подивитесь на екран -
одразу помітите закономірність.
Цукрові заводи
розташовані в зоні лісостепу.
Тому що для виробництва цукру,
так само як для виробництва олії,
значно більше потрібно сировини за вагою,
ніж готова продукція,
яка отримується в процесі переробки.
Якщо ми переробимо 100 кілограм буряків,
то ми отримаєм лише 15 кілограм цукру.
Отже,
перевозити цукор до споживача значно
вигідніше, з економічної точки зору,
ніж возити на великі відстані буряки.
Тому виробництво цукру і зосереджено
в основному в лісостеповій зоні,
де сірі лісові і типові чорноземні
ґрунти при достатньому зволоженні
дають найвищі врожаї цукрового буряка
і, відповідно, в сировинній зоні і
розміщені основні виробництва.
Виробництво цукру в Україні
зменшилося на відміну від
виробництва олії, істотно зменшилося.
Але залишається на рівні
понад 2 мільйони тон,
причому кожна четверта тонна цукру,
виробленого в Україні, експортується.
Перспективи цієї галузі пов’язані
з тим, що на світовому ринку
в окремі роки відчувається
істотний дефіцит цукру,
особливо виробленого із цукрового буряка.
Тому, нарощуючи виробництво
цукру, Україна може і надалі
збільшувати експортну виручку.
На цій карті
цукрові заводи також розміщені в
основному у зоні лісостепу і ми їх бачимо.
Рожеві пунсони дещо гірше аніж попередні.
Але зверніть увагу на те, що є окремі
виробництва і за межами цієї зони.
Чому?
Здається дивно, для чого
везти цукрові буряки так далеко
на південь Херсонської
чи Миколаївської області.
Але найвищі врожаї цукровий буряк дає
на поливних землях саме в цій місцевості.
Якщо фермер прорахує,
що витрати на забезпечення водою
його господарства перекриваються
високим врожаєм та доходом від
реалізації цукрового буряка,
то він буде його вирощувати.
І тут також є досить великі цукрові заводи
В портових містах вони можуть
переробляти цукрову тростину,
тому такі нюанси також
потрібно враховувати.
Разом з тим
на карті ми можемо побачити ще деякі
виробництва, які орієнтуються на сировину.
Якщо ви звернете увагу
на жовтенькі пунсони,
це виробництво крохмалю.
Крохмаль в Україні виробляє
не так багато підприємств.
Їх близько 1О-ти,
але особливості їх розташування
потрібно також проаналізувати.
Передусім ми бачимо, що ці підприємства
розташовані в основному у зоні мішаних
лісів і на заході лісостепової зони,
заходячи в зону широколистих лісів.
Тобто, це території, де в умовах
коли може бути тривалий
засушливий періодів влітку,
найкращі врожаї дає картопля.
І ось в цьому плані я б хотіла
показати вам дві фотографії.
Дві групи людей.
Одна з них - три брати.
Три брати Лазарі з Чернігівської області.
Сьогодні у них вже три підприємства.
І Чернігівщина
стає таким осередком виробництва
картопляного крохмалю в Європі.
Починаючи з 1994 року вони
наполегливо розвивали своє виробництво,
вкладаючи значну частину
свого прибутку в модернізацію,
розширення виробництва, створення нового.
А це Києво-Святошинський район,
де кілька друзів,
починаючи з ідеї переробки
некондиційної картоплі,
яка не підходить для виробництва,
наприклад, картоплі фрі в Макдональсі.
Вони придумали можливість
як отримувати високі доходи,
виробляючи картопляний
крохмаль, в тому числі і на експорт.
До галузей, які орієнтуються
на сировину належать
і плодоовочеконсервна промисловість.
Якщо ви подивитеся на ось цю картинку,
помітите що вона має географічний аспект.
Давайте почнемо з нижньої частини.
Ви звикли, що внизу на карті -
південь.
"Наш сік" і "Садочок" - Одещина,
Овідіопольські овочеві консерви,
Миколаївська область - "Сандора",
"Чумак" - Херсонщина.
Тобто, виробництво цих
продуктів на півдні області,
означає що тут
виробляється багато сировини,
її можна в доброму стані, в якісному
стані постачати на підприємство.
А це помідори, перці, виноград,
кісточкові культури, зібрані в садах.
І переробляти на високоякісні соки,
дитяче харчування, овочеві консерви.
При цьому, оцей ряд, якщо
ви спроектуєте на карту,
то ви зрозумієте - як
розташовані виробництва в Україні.
А у верхній частині ми бачимо "Торчин",
Рівненські огірочки,
зелений горошок "Верес",
Ніжинська кабачкова ікра.
Квасоля з Кропивницького
і огірочки Харківщини.
Що кидається у вічі?
Тут вже менше консервів,
вироблених із помідорів і перців,
з черешні чи вишні,
тут в основному ті культури, які
потребують більше вологи і менше тепла.
Відповідно і асортимент
консервів у них трохи інший.
Якщо ми цю картину спроектуємо
зараз на карту харчової промисловості,
то ми побачимо, що великі центри
плодоовочеконсервної промисловості -
це або великі міста, як наприклад Одеса,
або маленькі містечка в сировинній
зоні і, навіть, села і селища.
Наприклад, виробництво соків "Сандора"
розташовано в сільській місцевості.
Так само є ще дуже багато малих
виробництв, кілька сотень і в Україні, які
заповнюють сьогодні полиці наших магазинів
консервованими овочами та фруктами.
До галузей, які орієнтуються на
сировинний чинник,
належить і молокопереробна.
Молокопереробне виробництво -
це не тільки
пастеризоване молоко, в якого короткий
термін зберігання, або, наприклад, йогурти
чи свіжоприготовлений домашній сир,
це ще й ті продукти, які мають
досить тривалий термін зберігання
і можуть орієнтуватися
на виробництво сировини,
а готову продукцію
постачати до споживачів.
Прикладом таких виробництв є сири і масло.
В них досить великий термін зберігання,
а от для їх виробництва потрібно дуже
багато молока, незбираного молока,
яке має обмежений термін
зберігання, особливо влітку.
Його треба швидко від
ферми довезти на завод,
щоб воно під палючим сонцем
не нагрілося і не зіпсувалося.
Тому молокозаводи раніше розташовувались
майже у всіх районних центрах України.
А у великих містах могло бути
навіть кілька молокозаводів.
І на прикладі компанії "Молочний альянс"
я вам зараз покажу як свої
виробництва розташовує така компанія,
інвестуючи кошти в модернізацію
тих підприємств, які існували, і нових.
Подивіться, виробництво масла -
ось такий жовтий колір – Чернігівщина,
де одне з найбільших поголів’їв рогатої
худоби молочно-м’ясного напрямку,
Сумщина, Полтавщина, Хмельниччина.
Тобто виробництва
розташовуються в сировинній зоні.
При цьому багато компаній
мають виробництва, які розташовані
не тільки в сировинній
зоні, але й у великих містах.
Тоді вони зорієнтовані, в основному,
на те, щоб виробити продукцію,
що має короткий термін зберігання
і у свіжому вигляді вона має бути
поставлена в торговельну мережу міста.
Так працюють заводи в Києві,
Харкові, у Львові і в інших містах.
Якщо ми візьмемо виробництво борошна,
що є прикладом тих
виробництв харчової індустрії,
які орієнтуються переважно на споживача.
Перевозити і зберігати
пшеницю на елеваторах дешевше,
ніж забезпечити якісне
зберігання борошна,
яке потім має в сухенькому вигляді,
непошкоджене, в гарній упаковці
потрапити на полиці магазинів.
Тому, коли ми подивимось
на виробництво борошна,
ось карта,
і порівняємо ії з картою
на якій позначено картограмою
виробництво пшениці,
а в основному борошно в
Україні на 90% - пшеничне,
то можна помітити,
що ті області, де сконцентровані
великі обсяги виробництва пшениці,
не мають високого рівня
концентрації борошномельних підприємств.
Наприклад, та ж Херсонська,
Кіровоградська,
Дніпропетровська чи Полтавська.
В основному ці підприємства
зберігають пшеницю і направляюють її,
потім продають тим підприємствам,
які виробляють борошно
і постачають споживачу.
Подивіться, яка висока концентрація
цього підприємства в Київській області,
оскільки це місто-мільйонник,
і на його полицях ви побачите борошно,
вироблене безпосередньо в Києві,
Білій Церкві та інших містах.
Так само Харків. Друге за величиною місто
та багатолюдна область - висока
концентрація борошномельного виробництва.
Разом з тим, подивіться
на Запорізьку і Одеську.
Сьогодні в цих областях
виробляється багато борошна
не тому що великі обсяги споживання.
Наприклад,
кількість споживачів в Запорізькій
менша, ніж в Дніпропетровській.
Але є можливість постачати
борошно на експорт.
І Україна
є однією з країн, які є лідерами
за обсягом експорту борошна
і успішно виграє в конкурентній
боротьбі у інших країн, завойовуючи ринки
Азії, Північної Африки
і інших регіонів.
На карті харчової промисловості
багато міст,
які в вашій уяві
є багатогалузевими центрами
виробництва харчових продуктів.
Що це означає?
Що в них, окрім тих виробництв, про
які ми говорили, обов’язково будуть ті,
які працюватимуть на це місто і
ті міста, які розташовані поблизу.
Як правило, це випікання хліба в
кожному місті, велике воно чи маленьке.
Зверніть увагу, коли ви
купуєте хліб, ви дивитесь:
хліб хлібзаводу номер одинадцять.
Уявляєте скільки
хлібозаводів було в місті Києві?
Так само їх може бути
кілька в інших великих містах.
Є хлібзаводи великі, що
розташовані поблизу великого міста.
Вони тоді постачають хліб не тільки в
це місто, а і в ті, що знаходяться поруч.
У маленьких містах і селищах,
навіть, в селах є пекарні,
які виробляють хліб, печуть
для вас булочки і тістечка,
виробляють солодкі напої з
коротким терміном зберігання.
І тоді такі виробництва
формують промислові пункти.
Тобто село чи маленьке місто де,
всього на всього, одне підприємство,
яке виробляє якийсь вид харчової продукції
і тоді ми називаєм його
"промисловим пунктом".
Населені пункти де є
кілька таких підприємств,
різних галузей, підгалузей,
ми їх називаємо центрами
харчової промисловості.
Так от, особливістю харчової
промисловості України
є те, що в нас багато центрів,
пунктів, і, навіть, підприємств,
які розташовані далеко за
межами населених пунктів.
Наприклад, підприємство, яке
виробляє відомий вам напій "Кока-колу".
Воно знаходиться не в
селі, а за його межами -
там, де воно може використовувати
унікальні запаси прісних підземних вод.
І тому ми просто кажемо, що
найпростіше називати такі підприємства -
осередками виробництва харчових продуктів.
Перспективи розвитку
цієї галузі пов’язані з тим,
що населення України не зростає.
Але, якщо буде зростати
туристичний потенціал країни
і буде збільшуватись кількість
туристів, що приїздять до нас,
то потреби у харчових продуктах
будуть збільшуватись у середині країни.
Разом з тим Україна має
величезний експортний потенціал
для того, щоб забезпечувати
якісними продуктами харчування,
передусім вироблених з
екологічно чистої сировини,
на ринках високорозвинених країн Європи,
а також країн, що стрімко нарощують
споживчий потенціал: країни східної Азії,
Південної Азії, Південно-Західної,
Африки та інших регіонів.
На наступному уроці ми познайомимось
з вами із харчовою промисловістю світу
і ви зрозумієте - як закономірності,
які ми сьогодні відстежили
на уроці, в Україні
простежуються в цілому в
інших країнах світу та регіонах.
Дякую за увагу!